it was funny because okay in that era
where i was talking about about working
with nipping doing all of that i met t
fly during those times he had the studio
in the same building next to us okay but
i didn't know t fly but every day oh he
used to sleep at the studio we would
leave like we kind of was having money a
little bit you know we had cars see fly
was on the come up about to get a deal
with i think
sony epic whoever he had his deal with
right he was trying to get that deal and
but we i was so i was hearing all the
music that he was recording that wasn't
out and that's how i got familiar with
him
so by the time i'm working on get home
safely and i remember i was somewhere at
a truck stop on the road one day and
somebody came up to me and it's a true
story like randomly i swear to god like
two in the morning i'm at a little thing
looking through the little glass about
to get a ginger ale or some [ __ ] of
water and the dude's like he's staring
at me i'm obviously like okay he gonna
say something about music and he asked
me like how did you know to put t fly on
that song
and i was like damn
i mean i guess that's how he looked at
it you know like it just came out of
nowhere but not when we was recording t
fly was in that same building recording
so i was hearing his songs every day he
was recording three or four songs and i
realized i knew the songs before they
came out oh wow because i was hearing
them playing them all day while we was
just sitting there eating chilling i was
hearing them so by the time i got to
doing get home safely and i had to be
for still calling i asked i sat i went
in this room and i said could you do a
hook for me on this and then i'll do the
verse you know what i'm saying and i sat
there with him and he was like cool and
that's really how our collaborations
really started working you know i'm
saying after that one day it was like a
saturday i remember and i was like man i
got this beat bro i think that you would
kill it and we did still calling that
day and then i've been working with bro
literally ever since till [ __ ] i've seen
them last week yeah you guys i feel like
yeah we never really fell out you know
i'm saying because you know what i
understand what he does and he
understands what i do and we always
rocking and um you know i put out an ep
on opm like a five song ep and i end up
being on four songs not intentionally
but just being on songs but yeah me and
t fly working on some a collaboration
for the people man i'm glad you asked
nice so you guys gonna put up yeah opm
we're gonna plow the album oh [ __ ] yeah
that's together yeah yeah we already
working on it i was working on it before
that's a bullet cav exclusive so t fly
dom project on the way yeah i mean i
feel like you guys have such a crazy
chemistry yeah we're gonna do a whole
album we already we already more than
halfway in i kind of put it on pause to
finish the west side three but that's
how i got that intermission and it was
kind of like a warm up to introducing to
keep the vibes going for the album
people will hear it but we got a great
you know we gonna put out a great body
of work 2022. how many records you guys
have done
right now [ __ ] maybe 12 but only like
sounds like an album yeah but yeah
probably really like three or four that
i really want to keep we got a lot of
work to do but we're gonna put it out
though it's already on the books for
sure
yeah it's already on the books it's
something we've been working on